-Our next guest is
a very funny comedian
who you know from his work on
"Saturday night Live"
and "Curb Your Enthusiasm."
He is nominated for
an Emmy for his role in
"Mapleworth Murders,"
which is available to stream now
on The Roku Channel.
Let's take a look.
-It appears he was
killed with ham.
-Ham! He was killed with ham.
-Approximately 15 --
-15 minutes ago. 15 minutes ago.
I was going to say 15 minutes.
You saw me, right?
But the spit got caught
in my throat.
You didn't even pat my back to
see I was choking or not.
-There is definitely
foul play --
-Foul play going on here.
There's so much foul play in
this room, I can smell it.
Matter of fact,
we got to vent this room out,
'cause some more
foul play might happen.
-Please welcome back to the show
one of our favorites,
J.B. Smoove.
-[ Laughs ]
Man! I love that show.
Man, I love it.
-Yeah.
And it looks like
you're shooting
Season 2 of "White Lotus"?
[ Laughter ]
You are always the
sharpest-looking gentleman
in show business,
and it remains true today.
Look at -- Even your drink
matches your outfit.
-And see how I profiled myself.
See, I got my -- I told you
before you about this.
I got my right leg over
my left leg.
See?
-Uh-huh.
-And I bounce it.
I just bounce my leg.
Seth, they ought to make
full-length Zooms.
You know what I mean?
That's what Zoom is missing.
They need to --
-Oh, I see.
-You know how you have
the mirror by the front door?
You get dressed up,
and before you walk out
the door, you look at yourself.
You turn around,
see how your butt look
in your pants, and, you know,
brush the shirt off.
Got a little lint on your --
And you tap your collar.
You straighten your hat.
And you walk your ass
out the house.
Zoom needs to do
a full-length camera
so people can see each other
like they're in the same room.
Right now --
I'm from chest up right now.
I'm not comfortable.
I'm not comfortable at all.
-Well, I think a lot of people
like that part of Zoom
because they don't have to put
any thought into it.
But you are incapable of not
dressing head-to-toe, right?
-Incapable.
Inc-- I can't do it.
I got to get fully dressed now.
See?
I gotta get fully dressed.
I gotta be fully engaged
in what I'm --
-Can you lift a foot up?
Can we see exactly what
kind of footwear you have?
-You know what?
I don't have shoes on,
but I do have full pants on.
See, I got full pants on.
Now, I could run in the closet
and get a pair of shoes.
-No, no, no. Please, sir.
No, we would never ask that.
-We can take a walk.
But I may --
See, a matching belt.
I got to -- Now I've
got to stand like this
so you can see my matching belt,
and this is
uncomfortable right now to do
a whole interview like this.
-Oh, it's uncomfortable
for us to look at it.
-Yeah, you don't want
to see that.
-J.B., the last time
you were here,
we talked about Naked Thursdays.
And, you know, because, again,
a man like you,
who puts so much thought
into his clothes
needs to give himself, you know,
on whatever --
on the fourth day, he rested,
let's say.
You -- Are you still doing
Naked Thursdays?
-Of course. It doesn't stop.
You don't just stop
doing Naked Thursday.
That's tradition.
You know, it's like any holiday.
It's a holiday, but it's every
Thursday, you know?
It's kind of like
if you were celebrating
Easter or Christmas or
Thanksgiving every Thursday.
That's what it is.
Why not? Why not? Why not?
-Sure. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-That's what it is.
You can't stop doing
the stuff that works.
Seth, when something works,
you don't just stop doing it.
-No, you don't.
-You keep it going.
-Can I tell you something
that's working for me right now?
I was in New Jersey.
I was going through the
Lincoln Tunnel.
Billboard -- big billboard of
my friend J.B. Smoove
dressed like Julius Caesar.
-Yeah, man.
It has been a marvelous campaign
I'm doing right now,
based on the
Caesars Sportsbook app.
And I'm telling you,
they have loaded me up, man.
I have been --
I have embodied Caesar.
And, you know, I'm such an
authority figure, I feel like,
in my projection.
My projection.
And -- Come on, now. Look.
How can you go wrong with
these damn glasses, Seth?
Whoo! Look at that.
-Yeah, that's very good.
-And a goblet.
I walk around
with this damn goblet.
I've got a damn goblet
and then these glasses.
Oh!
-It's really good, J.B.
-It changed my posture, too.
I sit more like --
I sit more upright.
-Yep.
-And I look around like this.
See that?
-You know how you should
look around as Caesar?
Like this.
-Oh, oh, that's later on.
-Oh, that's later on?
-Don't kill me.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, you know what I mastered?
Here's what I mastered.
-What? What were you saying?
-I mastered this, too.
See? This?
-Oh, yeah.
-And this. See?
Down. See?
See? To the lions.
See? The tigers.
-You did "Shark Week"
with our friend Brad Paisley,
who is just -- I mean, if there
is a gentleman as fine as
J.B. Smoove, it's Mr. Paisley.
Now, is it true that you did
"Shark Week" thinking
that you had been asked to do
"Shark Tank"?
-Let me tell
you something, Seth.
Someone like myself,
with a ton of ideas,
would naturally hear the word
"Shark" -- right? --
and mute the last part.
I muted it, like -- like a mute
button on your phone,
like I don't want someone
to hear this.
I muted the part that said
"Shark Tank" -- "Shark Week,"
and I heard -- When I turned it
back on, I heard "Shark Tank."
You know?
-Yeah.
-And I'm loaded with ideas,
so I naturally thought
that that's where
I was going at, man.
-Can you give us --
If you were on "Shark Tank,"
I'm imagining you're a man
who has a few ready to go.
-[ Laughs ]
Come on, man. Come on.
Let's go.
First of all,
one of my main inventions,
I think, would be fabulous.
It is a pizza table.
It's called the Pizza Table.
It's a table made out of pizza.
And your whole family
sits around it.
Now, you order
the size you want.
Maybe you want the
individual pizza for yourself
or the per--
I call it a personal.
Personal pizza.
You've got the medium,
the small, and the large,
and the extra large
for a large family.
It's a pizza table.
The whole thing
is made out of pizza.
The whole table is edible.
The legs are
made out of breadsticks.
-Sure.
-Thick-ass breadsticks.
So you eat the pizza part,
then everybody gets a leg,
and they eat the leg, too.
See? No cleanup!
No cleanup. See?
-Well, that's -- I mean,
everybody's least-favorite part
about pizza is the cleanup.
-People hate the cleanup.
-Alright, wait.
Wait.
We have to go to commercial.
And I'm sure,
in this commercial break,
everybody will be rushing
to invest in Pizza Table.
-Of course they will.
-We'll be right back with more
inventions from J.B. Smoove.